many guys got some sequels coming at you
this weekend as purchased at the weekend
of sequels it's to sequined 22 Jump
Street so 22 Jump Street stars Channing
Tatum and Jonah Hill they're done with
high school that they were in the first
movie now they're in college that's
right they're undercover in college do
the exact same plot of the first movie
that drugs are circulating campus so
they've got to find the drugs and the
drug supplier seriously it's the same
block which is fine because the movie
addresses it they all but turn to the
camera be like that's right folks same
plot as the last movie to get the movie
credit for doing the whole if it ain't
broke don't fix it approach safe
approach for sure effective yeah because
it's enjoyable I enjoyed the movie I
laughed in the movie it does have some
unique plot points for this movie I
really liked what they did with Jonah
Hill and Channing Tatum's relationship
in this movie they start you know it's
one of those fork and the road things
where it's like are we really what we
want I love Jonah Hill and Channing
Tatum seriously the guy their chemistry
in this movie and the last movie I
couldn't imagine 21 or 22 Jump Street
without these guys it's just a day could
that ever happen ever no they are
awesome together this movie could
literally be the two of them sitting in
front of a fireplace in robes reading
the dialogue to Slingblade and if this
is two of them doing it it's probably
pretty interesting if not pretty funny
IceCube is great in the movie there's
one scene where he just has a meltdown
and I was like I want to see this guy
rage out and meltdown on everything can
he do that can he just make a youtube
clip of him just losing his [ __ ] I'd
watch that I would watch that more than
the collective people of the world have
watched that Gundam style video but I do
got to address the fact this movie does
on many occasions give me that feeling
of yeah I remember this movie I saw it a
couple years ago it was called 21 Jump
Street and I address it because it is
funny when a movie does that and
addresses the fact that it is
essentially a sequel and they break down
how sequels are and how they're not ever
is good and that this is in fact a
sequel and that does crack me up but
then when you see a lot of plot points
in this movie that are the same as the
last movie you can't help but just be
like really
hey here's how you make two comedies you
write a comedy and if it works you write
the same exact comedy for the second one
there you go two movies as long as you
have the act
in the movie ironically addressed the
fact to the audience that this is
essentially the same movie as the last
movie it's all good just seems weird to
me to give a movie like this a pass on
that it is cool when a movie is
self-aware of what it is because it can
play up the fact of what it is doesn't
change the fact that it feels like
writing the script is pretty much
phoning an intro scary movie pieces of
[ __ ] know what they are they don't get a
pass everyone shits on us what does 22
Jump Street get a pass because it knows
what it is it's just a weird excuse to
me to be clear I'm not [ __ ] on 22
Jump Street I actually enjoyed the movie
and I liked it not as much as 21 Jump
Street 21 Jump Street was clearly better
in my eyes probably because 21 Jump
Street was a surprise you come out of
that going holy [ __ ] that was good now
that 21 Jump Street was good you go into
22 Jump Street going alright I think
this could be good it better be good
that's my rant I felt like I had to
address it don't mistake that for
negativity because it's not negativity
it's not a negative review it's not a
bad movie just should I have to say
however the end credits in this movie
hilarious
I was watching the end credits going
this is the funniest thing in the movie
which is a bummer because as you're
watching it that concept makes the rest
of the movie feel less funny it doesn't
matter because as you're watching it
you're like this is hysterical so 22
Jump Street although not as good as 21
Jump Street was still funny it was still
enjoyable I like what they did with the
characters I like where Channing Tatum
and Jonah Hill's relationship went in
this movie it felt like a proper sequel
and ironically simultaneously felt like
a rehash and I will say 22 Jump Street
is a good time no alcohol required right
so 22 Jump Street have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more